mason is with us in tucson arizona hi
mason welcome to the dave ramsey show
hello sir thanks for having me today
sure man what's up
um so i am
you're cutting out brother you're going
to speak directly into your phone we
lost
can you hear me now yes sir okay so
i'm i'm new to the whole dave ramsey
saving your money i thought
i knew how to budget turned out i didn't
so
december 26th i bought your book total
money makeover
a couple days later i bought everyday
millionaire by chris hogan wow
in january 6th
10 days after that i sold my truck to
get rid of
twelve thousand dollars in debt that i
had wow and
now so my student loans
are 28 552
my net my net income is 43
um 886. monthly expenses
are about 1800 to 1900.
so my question is i have a wedding
coming up in august
um i have 10 000
in savings right now do i
put some of the money and savings
into the student loan debt or do i hold
on to it
for future wedding expenses
i would figure out what my wedding
expenses and hold that much back and
throw the rest of it towards a student
loan
do you have a wedding budget yet
um we do like it so we're paying for a
good majority and that
our parents are paying for some too uh
pretty much everything is done we just
have to get
like you know settled with the bartender
the photographer
you know little stuff like that good
good which are pricier items though
mason photographer and bartender
so yeah just figuring out how much you
guys have left to spend
um so whatever that amount is yes then
you can take some of that ten thousand
use it for that
save keep that thousand dollars your
baby emergency fund and then everything
else you can throw out the student loan
so if you were going to guess what is
your part left to pay on the wedding
just off the top of your head off the
top of my head
probably with bartenders photographers
probably around five thousand i'd say
okay we'll use that as an example what
you what i want you to do i want you to
dig into it and make that number solid
because i don't want you to come up
short okay
okay so if it's five thousand four
hundred and sixty two dollars set five
thousand five hundred aside okay
so just go ahead and dial it in get it
dialed into the penny like you did on
the other stuff you've done a really
good job you jumped on this man
you jumped on it hard and uh that that
gives me a lot of hope for you guys that
there is listen there is nothing like a
quick start a quick start will get you
moving
and that's what you've done i'm proud of
you so get that dialed in
set that money aside don't touch it
that's the wedding it's already spent
you just hadn't given it to them yet
okay and you won't have you don't have
to worry about that it's over
then you set one thousand dollars aside
in another account as your little
starter baby step one
emergency fund and then as rachel said
you're just gonna take the risk of it
and throw it at the student loans and
now everything out of your budget
boom boom boom we're gonna smack the
crud out of those student loans between
now
and marriage and you know what you're
going to be well on your way on that by
the time you get there because
if you throw four or five grand at those
things now and then you've got a couple
grand a month to throw at them
between now and then you're going to be
popping them
okay okay you're doing good yeah did
your does your fiance have
a lot of debt mason when you guys get
married she has no debt
awesome amazing yeah and then you're
going to combine your incomes when you
guys get married
as well so i mean like you'll yeah so
how thrilled is she
and her dad that you're doing this
uh she's excited she's really excited
she i mean
she made comments about how you know i
was spending too much and stuff like
that and i
i didn't realize it until i sat down
and actually looked at everything where
everything was going and then it just
opened my mind
so no she she loves how old are you two
uh we're both 25 awesome very good
listen we're going to give you a wedding
gift i want you to the two of you to be
in ramsey plus
for a year free as our gift as our
wedding gift
and that includes financial peace
university it includes every dollar the
premium version
includes the baby step app and right now
it's got a quick 90-day start which is
the game plan you are on baby you are a
quick start dude
and uh there is uh no one regrets
getting a quick start
ever oh well the progress automatically
and it's like oh it just feels it's
it's great that's powerful powerful well
done so
hold on zach will pick up mason and
we'll get you signed up for ramsey plus
for a year
you and the fiance and you guys can
start tracking with each other
and that'll that'll take all the stuff
you're doing and really
really dial it in it's the detailed plan
to show you exactly what to do and how
to do it and
you're really cooking man you're doing
really good i'm so proud of you